-Thank you for being here.
It so nice to see you again.
This is the first time
meeting you in person.
-I know.
-You were nice enough to do
a Zoom with us last time.
-Yeah.
-And I appreciate that. Is this
your first press tour in person?
-It is. It is my first
press tour in person.
And even doing the walk out here
is quite scary.
You're like, "I don't know
how to walk places."
[ Laughter ]
-You forgot how to really walk?
-I've forgotten how to walk.
When you think about it too
much, it's quite, like --
it's a strange thing, you know?
You over sort of think
everything.
But anyway, yeah, it's lovely
to be in person, finally.
-Yeah, I'm happy
that you're here.
I know you've done -- you're
doing -- You're so busy.
You're doing
all these movies now.
You haven't been to London
in a while,
which is where you're from?
-Last year, I wasn't there.
Well, I was there
for about 10 days-ish.
-I wanted to make you feel
at home,
so I got some of your favorite
crisps from England.
-Oh!
-Now, these are --
I don't know
if I've ever had these.
What are these?
-Oh, my gosh.
Okay, so these are Hula Hoops.
-Has anyone had these?
-You ever had Hula Hoops?
[ Cheers ]
-Yeah, five people are familiar
with Hula Hoops. Yeah.
-We got a whoop for Hula Hoops.
[ Laughter ]
-What are they?
-Hula Hoops are
a circular crisp.
[ Laughter ]
-A circular crisp.
-And it's almost looks like --
So, you know,
when you're in primary school,
you put them all
on your fingers, like rings,
and then you eat them off.
-Oh, that's fun. Yeah.
-It's so much fun.
-Do you have a favorite flavor?
What should I go with?
-I would say
the traditional would
be an already salted Hula Hoop.
-Alright, so this is
an original. Here we go.
This is my first Hula Hoop.
I've never had this.
-So funny for hula hoops.
-That's what they look like.
Okay.
-You got to put it on
your fingers first.
-Of course, yeah.
I don't know if they'll fit on
my fingers.
[ Laughter ]
I think you were a little --
you were a little girl
when you did this.
Alright.
♪♪
Oh, yeah. These are phenomenal.
No, no, I love it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, I love these.
-You like?
-Yeah.
-Oh, good.
-That might be
my new favorite thing.
Hula Hoops, I love these.
These are great. I'm into these.
What are these?
-These are Quavers.
-What's Quavers?
-Quavers are a cheesy,
curled crisp.
-Are you just reading the bag?
[ Laughter ]
These are circular.
So this is cheesy curled.
Now, you don't put these on
your fingers?
-You can do if you want to.
They might fit better.
-This might fit better
than the other ones.
This actually fits my finger
more than the --
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
What in the world?
-You like?
[ Applause ]
-Try these, man, Quavers.
Quavers.
-Quavers?
-Quavers.
-Wow!
-That's what I'm talking about,
dude. Come on.
I don't mess around, dude.
Well, I wanted to maybe have you
try something
that you haven't tried,
so I talked to your publicist.
And I said, "Is there -- Can I
just name some things that maybe
Daisy hasn't tried?"
And I found out that you'd never
had Girl Scout cookies.
[ Audience oohs ]
-No.
-This is a very American thing,
and we love the Girl Scouts.
Now, it's a big debate of
which is the best one.
Of course,
I have my personal fave.
-What are they?
What are the differences?
-Well, alright, look.
Take a peek.
This one here is --
Oh, yeah, Caramel deLites
is what they're called now.
They had a different name
when I was growing up.
This is Caramel deLites.
It's like, coconut, caramel.
It's unbelievable.
These are peanut butter patties.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Getting some --
The crowd loves that.
Peanut butter sandwich.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then Thin Mint.
Alright, wait,
so where would you go?
Would you go --
-Well, I --
-This is -- The caramel one
would be what I would order.
-That's yours?
-Yeah.
-I feel like whoop was
quite loud for the mint.
-Yeah, it was. Yeah.
So let's try --
Should we try the Thin Mints?
-I'd be happy to try that too.
-Yeah.
Why don't you try
that one first?
Because I feel like
I know the answer.
[ Laughter ]
It's going to be probably
Thin Mints, so yeah.
-Is there a big source of debate
what the best one is?
-Yes.
-Okay.
You can try a bite of this.
You're going to freak out.
Yeah, you can put it on
your finger if you want to.
[ Laughter ]
Out of all of these,
that's the most wearable. Yeah.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Oh!
-Right?
That's something.
It's like a macaroon.
-Yeah.
-It's not bad, right?
-I'm surprised, actually.
-You're surprised?
You enjoy these?
-It didn't look as appetizing
as it is.
-Yes, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
You're not supposed
to look at them, really.
Okay, here we go.
The Thin Mints.
I mean, I didn't know they come
in two tubes of like --
Alright, get ready.
I already kind of know.
This is -- Yeah.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
-Yep, here we go.
Daisy Edgar-Jones.
Yeah, basic. Right?
Wait, wait. Hold it, wow.
Wait a second. Look at this.
I've never seen this. Wait.
What do you mean "that"?
Mine?
Yes, exactly right!
Oh, I love it!
I love you! Come on!
That's exactly right.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
These are the best ones.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love you, Girl Scouts.
I always support
the Girl Scouts.
But I love you love mine. Good.
Yeah, I love Thin Mints.
The secret, though, right,
you freeze them. Right?
[ Audience shouts "yeah" ]
Yeah, that's the secret thing.
If you freeze a Thin Mint,
it's a whole different ride.
I want to talk about your film,
"Fresh."
Can we talk about this?
This is getting great reviews,
by the way, so congratulations
on that.
[ Applause ]
It's better not to know anything
beforehand though?
-I think so.
I think the joy of the film is
coming to it not knowing where
it goes because it really
does go on quite a journey.
-Yeah.
-But, yeah, I would describe it
as a sort of --
a social thriller about
the perils of modern dating.
That's kind of one way
you could describe it.
But yeah.
It's one of the things too.
-Yeah.
It's -- but it's -- it's dark.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-But I don't want to ruin it.
-It's dating. But it's -- Yeah.
-Yeah.
-And Adam McKay --
did he produce it?
-He did. Yeah, he was
one of the producers.
-I love Adam McKay.
But this -- it goes --
Like, you do not see
where this goes at all.
And then it goes for --
I mean, it's a good --
You get a full ride.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, you're amazing in it.
It's really, really well done.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Daisy Edgar-Jones
and Sebastian Stan in "Fresh."
Take a look at this.
-I hate, like, dating, you know?
Everything about it.
Do you like
the awkward preamble?
Like, questions and stuff.
The, like, you know, texting.
The perfect projection.
-Yeah.
-Everything about it.
Honestly.
I don't know.
I just think that, um,
people who, like, believe in
true love are [bleep] idiots.
-So dumb.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Daisy Edgar-Jones!
"Fresh" begins streaming
this Friday on Hulu.